monsieur premier ministre ce jeudi de
mai dernier amboise ville paisible des
bords de loire
le président emmanuel macron a rencontré
le président italien sergio matarelle à
cette rencontre avait pour objet de
célébrer la personnalité universel de
léonard de vinci mort il ya 500 ans
cet événement symbolique rappelé
l'amitié franco-italienne quelque peu
mise à mal et surtout préfigurer en en
donnant le coup d'envoi les festivités
des 500 ans de la renaissance en val de
loire
tout portait donc à s'attendre à un
moment festif pour la population mais
une tornade sécuritaire s'est abattue
sur la ville
je ne résiste pas à la curiosité de vous
détailler les consignes passées aux
habitants circulation interdite en ville
de 7h à 17h
stationnement interdit toute la journée
et depuis la veille 7 heures du matin
interdiction d'aller et venir pour les
piétons de 7h à 13h à proximité du
château
interdiction pour les habitants envisagé
dans un premier temps de paraître aux
fenêtres et balcons finalement annulé
interdiction bien sûr de manifester mais
aussi de naviguer sur la loire cette
ville touristique de 13 mille habitants
très active
accueillant près d'un million de
visiteurs par an s'est trouvée bouclé et
désertée une ville fantôme vidée de
toute vie un véritable désert commentent
les habitants bloqués chez eux tous les
commerces ont leurs rideaux baissés une
ambiance aussi impressionnante que
ridicule
on peut rétorquer qu une menace
terroriste est toujours présente
ressortez alors l'image de la visite du
général de gaulle en 1959
émergeant d'une marée humaine en liesse
au pied du château vu pareille ville de
rome cette ville sous cloche
comme le titrait le journal local
marquer peut-être un signe fort de
l'amitié franco-italienne est vu
d'amboise c'était la sidération l'image
d'une ville parfaitement ville au
conclure il y annonce de questions à se
poser sur les rapports d'un président
avec le peuple il de ce pouvoir avec la
nation ma question est la suivante le
traitement la sécurité par le vide et qu
il vraiment nécessaire et accessoirement
s'agit-il là aussi d'une nouvelle
doctrine sécuritaire pour les
déplacements présidentiels comme on
répond de la parole était valable à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs center monsieur le sénateur il
est évident que il faut à chaque fois
qu'il y à un hôte étranger du niveau du
président italien faire en sorte que la
sécurité soit garantie aux meilleurs
mais nous étions la semaine dernière
dans des circonstances exceptionnelles
dont vous avez connaissance quelques
jours avant et je n'entrerai pas plus
dans les détails
quatre personnes ont été interpellées
parce que l projeté un attentat
directement contre l'elysée directement
contre les forces de sécurité de
l'elysée
l'enquêté se poursuit l' enquête se
poursuit une interpellation a eu lieu
aujourd'hui même pour compléter
l'instruction elle est placée sous
l'autorité du procureur de paris dans le
cadre de ses seins pour des activités
terroristes et donc il nous a semblé
nécessaire d'être particulièrement
vigilants ensuite j'ai eu connaissance
le seul sénateur de demande qui me
semblait peut-être disproportionné ce
que vous évoquez je ne le met nullement
en cause correspond peut-être à des
mesures de sécurité qui ont été
amplifiées par un souci de protection et
de précaution maximum nous avons décidé
d'enlever quelques unes les élus locaux
et la presse locale nous a interrogés
nous aurons décidé d'enlever quelques
unes parce que justement il nous
semblait peut-être pas tout à fait
adapté pas tout à fait proportionnée
puisque je veux dire monsieur le
sénateur et je suis sûr que nous nous
retrouvons tous c'est que quand il
s'agit de célébrer un moment aussi
important que celui ci mais surtout de
faire en sorte que la sécurité d'un
président de la république quel qu'il
soit et d'un prison étrangers invités
soient au meilleur niveau il nous faut
pour cela prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions dans le cadre d' un risque
terroriste qui hélas est permanent je
remercie